how's chris pratt as a boss not great
what everyone keeps saying buddy thanks
so much
he's incredible here he is she's talking
about you as a boss
oh hey okay you water or
everything okay she said not great we'll
see we'll see sorry about the eye
contact i know you said i know
first of all i didn't say that my people
said that okay get it right
the word tyrant has been thrown around
is that right good
good i've got him right where i want him
these little gnomes that stab your
ankles
wow just kidding it was a true joy
wonderful okay i'll let you a good
person
you're going to be more movies yeah okay
okay here is the thing uh the the word
tyrant has been thrown around diva all
these things
you as an ep wow wow that's good
i've got him running scared i'm gonna
just focus on what you said ep
i was the executive producer on this
amazing movie and here we are the
tomorrow awards on amazon prime
july 2nd you can see it this friday
and we're really excited to be here it
is incredible i know you guys made it
like two years ago at this point and i
just love that it's gonna be the summer
blockbuster that we've all missed what
was it like for you to do that ep thing
for the first time though i mean
chris the director was singing chris
producers praises saying you were super
involved
oh that's so nice it's an effort it
takes a village no matter what the
titles are
it's a really collaborative art form
making a big movie like this
um it's it's not that dissimilar to
having starred in other movies i guess i
just come on a little earlier
the aliens chris i get to help
i get to give a creative input as to the
sound of the alien
a little we did pretty well i mean a
little it's a little bit of an homage to
your other works a little
yeah yeah you're talking about parks and
rec of course
look did you say to yourself i've fought
dinosaurs in the past how can i up the
ante
aliens from the future in a way yes in a
way yes
i you know i it was important to me to
do one
really big movie that year and i and uh
and this was the one it's original which
is something that um
i i feel like there have been a lot of
cravings for something
that isn't based on a sequel or a comic
book or something it's like a big movie
that's original
and so this script uh came along and it
was just great and so we made it
i wanted to say congrats on your
anniversary thank you did your lovely
wife clip your toenails for tonight
that is a secret yes you did
and they look amazing look you guys i
mean you're so cute that post was so
sweet a couple years in what's what's
one relationship tip you'd give all of
us how are you guys staying so happy and
then just enjoying like
oh communicate communicate yeah listen
listen to your partner with intention
you know and uh
care about each other's feelings and uh
and you know be each other's uh support
one another and just you know listen
awesome thank you um so excited for
guardians of the galaxy three but real
quick
are we gonna see star-lord in the new
black panther movie will he make an
appearance
gosh i can't tell you anything about
marvel i'm so sorry i want to tell you
everything i want to sit here and just
talk about it it's really it's about to
come out but i'm not going to say
anything
okay but amazing i think to see all the
casts come together and to honor
chadwick of course
oh yeah of course yeah they're he's
irreplaceable
and uh and the beauty of
and and really the gift of what we get
to do is not only just play for a living
but
put ourselves into a medium that will
actually
out live us and uh inspire people
and it's he will inspire people for as
long as people can watch movies
forever real quick independence day
weekend you guys are coming out aliens
yeah are you giving independence day a
run for its money i think so
we definitely took uh tonal
notes from independence day uh it's
something that's
a great movie in a movie that came up in
the
in the process of uh really honing this
script for tone
we love i love that movie it's got equal
parts comedy
uh heart action um i think
i think it's we're better i think we did
it better i really do i think our alien
is scary
make sure you go to the bathroom before
you sit down to watch the movie
and also make sure to turn your phone
off i know they always tell you that at
the theater and you go oh i gotta turn
my phone off but isn't it such a better
experience i mean do we really have to
have our faces on our phone i'm like
that grandpa now but turn your phone off
you'll enjoy the movie more amazing
congrats thank you so much thank you